Ralph why are you stirring up so much
[__] yeah oh geez man La Raza why are
you doing that dude yeah
[Laughter]
saying like a Mexican's worst enemy is
another Mexican oh [__] yeah and it's
true I don't like these Mexicans
um listen obviously there's this beef
everybody's going around I don't even
know if it's beef I don't think so I
thought it was fine
uh I thought it was fine for real like
yeah I mean you did put a video out
where you were killing him yeah I put
out the I put out the edited version I
have a director's cut
I just thought it was funny because I
like I like that movie like Carlito's
Way yeah and I like the thought of like
taking out the old dudes but the the
reason that I put that video up was
because like I like I just started being
on the road and so every now and then
somebody will be like you're the next
George Lopez even before the stores low
fisting my response was already like yo
[__] George Lopez oh really whenever
somebody would yell that from the
audience or any Latino comedian they
throw out whoever their Idols were I was
like [__] your Idols
um but when that thing came out I was
just like oh this is pretty this is like
what I've been saying yeah is that was
that a real sentiment or just I'm trying
to get a laugh on stage when they say it
or was your brain really like yo I'm I'm
coming for it [__] all these guys I
wasn't really like coming for them it's
just that when they would name them I'm
like
I don't know like sometimes it's a funny
thing to say on stage yeah it's funny to
say I just think it's funny that they're
just like assuming
I like looked up to George Lopez that's
the thing I was I wanted to ask you when
you came up because you're 26 yeah
I'm 39. yeah and I felt I was young when
I was watching George Lopez yeah so I
wasn't watching I don't think you ever
grew up watching them even when I was
watching them I was like I don't get it
oh come on no that [__] is
hilarious yes
I think it was funny I like yeah he's
funny but I didn't think he was like I'm
not like gonna like yo man I want to
watch this George Lopez like special or
like all the [__] shows gonna come on
like I'll hear people quote them all the
time yeah and I'm like yeah I gotta I
gotta see that one day and then when I
didn't bring it I'm like yeah that's so
funny my chest yeah like that I don't
know
how many now this is what it is it's
like comedy you need comedy within the
context of time because this is how I
felt about prior because I saw Eddie
first so everybody would tell me oh my
God Pryor's the truth he's the greatest
ever and I grew up on Eddie so when I
saw Pryor I was like no he's not [__]
with Eddie yeah this is this feels like
I know this feels it's like blasphemy I
almost said it feels like a less funny
version of this guy who is the king for
me so you're coming up and also comedy
changing like I imagine when George was
putting out that first special
this is like this is the first time
Mexicans are seeing a guy relate and
share their experiences in a comedic way
especially on [__] HBO so they're
seeing other guys they're seeing Rock
they're seeing Carl in they're seeing
all these other dudes and finally it's
like oh [__] yeah he's talking that
thing that I've experienced whereas
you're watching it and you've seen all
these jokes played out for 20 or 30
years by different people different
versions so if you go back to it you go
yo there's better versions of all these
takes yeah I guess so I don't know I
didn't
like I wasn't like huge into standard
growing up though like yeah
and if I was watching stand up I was
watching whoever came on TV around that
time yeah so it's like Comedy Central so
it was a lot of like of like Chappelle's
thing or like Patrice O'Neill's like
special like reruns of theirs like type
of stuff for Clips or whatever and by
the time I did see like a George Lopez
clip or something like that
um
I just remember he kept saying
like stuff like Latinos you know us and
I like that was like the corniest line
in the world to me yeah for anybody to
say like you know us man yeah we get
down or like this is like I don't know I
couldn't get into it to this point so
not saying it's not funny I just I just
couldn't get into it yeah George Lopez
side now [__] these young kids
it's almost like it's like when young
dudes look at the rap ogs and the rap
seems so simple they're just a hip hop I
hit it yeah you know what I'm saying and
you're just like what that's what I'm
watching yeah that's what it feels like
I'm watching George yes but at the time
that Dr Sue [__] was fire I bet
yeah not to say he's not funny like
I'm like yeah he's funny as [__] it's
just like I don't know I'm not gonna
watch him to his point you were like
three when The George Lopez Show came on
the air you were like five or six when
the special came up yeah so that thing
back then to his point it's like the way
when Indians when we saw Russell I'm old
enough to like see the beginning I
really felt exactly like what he said
like yo we've never heard anybody
talking to us holy [__] I'm so happy
this is so funny young kids coming up
now watching that are gonna be like yo
there's a hundred Indian Comics this one
he's doing this simple thing it's like
no back then that was it that was the
only thing yeah and George back then
nobody was talking to them
Mexican comedian yeah you're a comedian
is Mexican okay I see it yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah but you needed a
Mexican comedian so that I could be a
comedian that's Mexican yes all right
you know because you're not going up
there like I gotta tell you everything
about being Mexican today you ready yeah
somebody already told him you know us
Mexicans yeah yeah now I do actually
because now I get it that's why you
don't have to because now we know dead
ass we're like we know Mexicans now
because George Lopez taught us yeah he
and he's like nice I'm telling you the
dude called me after that whole thing he
said whatever he like I wasn't mad when
he said it yeah because like like I'm
telling you like I have like a whole lot
of respect from still I'm not when he
said it I'm not like uh what the [__]
like heard about it but I also wasn't
like well yeah okay it just was like
it's a [__] podcast you're talking
[__] like yeah so what if he said you
know I mean like he doesn't know me so
like it's his he knows you my boy but
it's his podcast like you don't say I
don't know somebody five times unless
you know unless you know but yeah he
called me and he was like super cool I
was kind of like Starstruck by it to be
honest because I wasn't expecting it but
how did he call it was he like like
this is George man George Lopez I was
like I want her to call and apologize
and my first verse was like what the
[__] and I was like my bad man I didn't
mean to be like rude or nothing it's
just like damn kind of caught me off
guard you know that he's even calling me
and he was just like yeah man he's like
I just I was kind of like in the Heat of
the Moment we're just kind of shooting
the [__] with with Trevino and kind of
fired up about it but I didn't mean I
didn't mean to like talk badly about you
anything like that like just kind of
talking [__] you know like but I
apologize I was like you didn't have to
man I was like I appreciate that a lot
like you usually didn't have to you know
it's not like bugging me like that he
was like no no he's like I did I had to
whatever he's like that's decent though
that he didn't do a public apology yeah
I I I wouldn't have
I don't think it has to be public at all
a lot of people online were like [__]
you slander him in public you apologize
nah bro like then it would have looked
like he's just doing it yeah not for you
yeah he's just like he's like Comics
comic man to man he's like I just want
to apologize man yeah he's like you got
my number if you ever did need help with
anything you got my number now oh that's
cool yeah that's cool as [__] you gonna
take him up on that see if he's about it
I'll probably wait till I'm like in a
really tough Jam yeah
murder trial at that time
he was cool it's that Steve Trevino guy
I'm starting to think he's the Batman
it is weird with the with the OG's I
think that like and again you're a few
Generations away from George but I think
the perception of the people that we
look up to is
for at least from us you know like like
with me Patrice is my guy and whenever I
had the opportunity to interact with him
like I almost removed myself from it
because I was like I don't want to
inconvenience him I don't want to ask
him for help I don't want to ask him for
things like and probably they're twofold
it's like one I don't want to be
rejected by someone I admire so much and
also like he could never have time for
me but I think we forget that like
they're also Comics despite their
success so they're also looking for some
validations from appreciation especially
from like the next crop so they would
probably love if we reached out and love
we're like yo can I just get any advice
is there anything you know I'm about to
experience something you experienced
earlier in your career Etc and yeah like
I guess maybe
yeah I don't know if you've ever felt
that about like an OG that you looked up
to
nah you got it nah it's not that I think
I like taking advice from whoever man
like yeah
I do get what you mean though it's like
uh I've looked up to this person I don't
want to like Risk pissing them off or
like being told something that's going
to put me off to them yeah but
I didn't really uh start admiring a lot
of the comedians out there and so I got
a chance to meet them personally then I
was just like yo this is actually really
cool like yeah this person's super funny
and stuff and then they started kind of
helping me out so I kind of went in like
neutral like I didn't I didn't there
wasn't anybody who was like oh [__] I
get to work with this person like yeah
give me advice yeah I just kind of
kicked back it was just like man whoever
I get to work with I'll work with them
if they kick advice they kick advice
like yeah I'll take it from whoever you
know I don't know the situation but my
assumption of it is is
a lot of times when people try to relate
to a comedian
they they talk about other comedians
that are funny and that's the last thing
a comedian wants like don't tell me this
other motherfucker's funny so I'm
imagining George is getting a lot of
people they're trying to Curry favor
with him going yo have you heard about
this young guy you like this young guy
so he's hearing this Non-Stop and now
he's on his podcast another guy's
bringing it up and he's like yo what the
[__] is going on over here I'm George
Let's Talk About Me Maybe I I I do know
like at the beginning of that podcast
they were talking about
Paul Rodriguez I think oh yeah he had
like some beef with Paul Rodriguez I
don't know what it was I think they got
into it over a joke I think they fought
at the Laugh Factory yeah and then he
was saying how he was how like I think
people wanted him to like apologize to
Paul or for talking [__] about Paul he
was just like it's it's like what do you
say like oh it's a [__] podcast like
just talking [__] man yeah and then
so I don't know they they went on to the
subject of like do you
do you help the younger guys and George
was like I don't help nobody yeah and
then he was probably like a little fired
up yeah yeah that's that's one of the
reasons that it didn't bug me is because
he was already like yeah
proven that like I don't [__] help
people like yeah [__] him [__] I think I
feel like they could have named anybody
and he would have been like yeah [__]
that guy yeah he also at one point if
you look I have heard he's not the most
helpful guy to be fair I've also heard
that three-dimensional about it but
there's also a moment where he looks off
camera and asks his homie like you heard
of this guy and the guy says no and I
think he's laughing at George George
looks at him and like lifts his eyebrows
every comic knows we got a guy going off
camera we gonna [__] go so then then
he goes I don't know [__] Jeremy
barbasol or whatever yeah I think he's
just trying to make his homie laugh and
he's wrapped up in it and he's got the
emotion yeah like I think he just feels
like he got a guy laughing yeah that's
Bill momentum yeah I don't think it was
I don't think it was that personal I
think it was very much like a whoever it
could have been my name is arbitrary is
that is that how you use it it really
stumbled on it dude I almost thought
that's what your name was
and also a word could have got back to
him like you said um people would say at
your show is like oh yeah like [__]
George Lopez word got back to him and
now he's like yo that's true heard his
young kids popping you know yo that is
true but my defense would be the same
like I don't know I was talking [__]
yeah it's a show it don't [__] matter
yeah if it if it's like
really get into anybody I think I think
they they would have like told me
something personally you know what I
mean yeah all right I don't think he's
heard about it I don't think have you
met Comics before
I probably said that once like in
Detroit or like Milwaukee where I was
just they're like you know George lope I
was like man [__] George Lopez like
you're the next Paul I was like oh it
gets back to them bro yeah there's some
guy in Milwaukee right on the letter
like boy you don't you're not gonna
believe it man and they just get upset
they're sensitive too you don't think
they are you like like I had a [__] and
it's it I'm glad that you don't look up
to him because it doesn't matter as much
but when you admire them and then they
let you down like that that [__]
that is uh it stays with you yeah it's
just yeah it's just like I remember
there was a
um it would hurt if like Russell Crowe
was like [__] that Jeremy Barber saw
what the [__] Gladiator doesn't like me
yeah
like Spaniard hates me
yeah it was uh yeah it's always tricky
man I remember Chappelle was on on Rogan
and uh and Rogan is the best he's always
trying to like give everybody a shout
out and put everybody on and he was like
yo you know you're doing he was like
Chappelle you're doing these great shows
outside you know in the barn or whatever
and and uh there's another guy who's
doing a lot of great stuff online this
guy Andrew Schultz he's doing these
videos online and turn your phone and
he's writing jokes and there's images
and Chappelle's just goes yeah I don't
know about that slideshow [__] uh I do
stand-up comedy and it was just like I
remember watching like oof that would
hurt damn like I was upset and then I
realized that like
it's a probably similar situation where
like people around Chappelle thinking
they're going to connect with him by
going hey have you checked this guy out
he's also funny and he's a comic he
don't want to hear about that [__] he
only hears about how he's funny like
I've had friends who just have random
shows in New York saying that he'll like
bring me up on stage and like you know
take little shots damn they're they you
can't it could be the top of the game
George Lopez Dave they'll hold on to
[__] that's nuts yeah and the lesson is
to not let that happen to you because
there will come a time you keep going
you're going to be the king and there's
gonna be a [__] that's gonna
take your spot to the youth because
you're gonna be old you're gonna be 46
56 and you got to remember I can't be
like that yeah I gotta break that
pattern everybody too Benny Blanco until
they get Benny blancoed yeah yeah
exactly 100 but right now it's my time
so I'll enjoy it there you go